[Musique]
par essence hostile à l'homme l'eau est
un élément avec lequel les armées
doivent pouvoir composer en toutes
circonstances
océan mère intérieure ou cours d'eau il
est à la fois environnement obstacle ou
frontières mais aussi lieu de transit et
vecteurs d'infiltration des
caractéristiques qui font de la maîtrise
de ce milieu un enjeu majeur pour toute
force armée objectif la supériorité
technique tactique opérative voire
stratégique
pour l'atteindre l'armée française peut
s'appuyer sur des soldats spécialistes
en la matière
ils sont plongeurs de bord plongeurs
démineur nageurs de combat sauveteur
plongeur ou encore plongeur de combat du
génie
et tous ont fait de l'eau une seconde
nature immersion dans le quotidien de
ces soldats de l'eau
ancien plongeur Jean-Jacques Margerie a
passé 41 ans dans la Marine nationale
l'histoire de la plongée militaire il la
connait sur les bouts des doigts
les plus vieux documents que l'on trouve
concernant cette aventure cette épopée
dirait date des environs 1850
ou la Marine a décidé de former des gens
en premier lieu pour récupérer tout ce
qui tombait à l'eau ou pour intervenir
sur les
œuvres vives du bateau c'est à dire tout
ce qui est en dessous de la ligne de
flottaison
jusqu'à l'entrée de guerre la capacité
et l'autonomie du plongeur est
contrainte par un matériel qui n'a que
très peu évolué le plongeur est relié à
la surface il n'est pas encore autonome
donc sa motricité et sa mobilité de fait
en est réduite
il faut attendre les années 1930 puis le
second conflit mondial pour qu'une
petite révolution est lieu dans le monde
de la plongée militaire l'invention des
premiers blocs de plongée et leur
perfectionnement permettent aux
plongeurs de passer sous l'eau d'une
position verticale à une position
horizontale avec une totale liberté de
mouvement
il a fallu attendre l'invention d'un
appareil révolutionnaire le fameux
cg42 CG pour Cousteau gagnant 42 pour
1942 qui par la suite a été modernisé et
a évoluer jusqu'à devenir le fameux
Mistral et là la marine va en acheter
des quantités et va commencer la
formation du personnel plongeur de bord
à partir de ce moment là un tout nouvel
horizon se profile pour le métier de
plongeur au sein de la Marine nationale
c'est le début d'une nouvelle ère
dès l'immédiate après guerre
l'état-major général de la marine a
commencé à réfléchir à l'emploi
opérationnel
du personnel qui va dédier à la plongée
aucune Marie n'a besoin et même aucune
armée au monde ne peut plus s'en passer
mais au lieu d'un grenouille on dit
plongeur de bord plongeur démineur
nageurs de combat une réflexion qui
aboutit en 1952 à la création du
commando uber accord d'élite de nageurs
de combat dont la réputation n'est plus
à faire et qui fait rêver tous les
jeunes plongeurs de l'armée française
le Commando Hubert c'est l'unité des
nageurs de combat de la Marine qui mène
les missions offensives de plongée de la
Marine nationale et du Commandement des
Opérations Spéciales grâce à leur blog
de plongée en circuit fermé ils sont
capables de s'infiltrer en toute
discrétion sur des kilomètres et s'ils
se sont aujourd'hui laissés filmer ces
hommes ont pour vocation d'être
invisibles indétectable
contre terrorisme lutte contre le
narcotrafic renseignement action coup de
poing ces soldats d'élite sont triés sur
le volet pour entrer au commander uber
c'est une sélection qui est extrêmement
difficile seulement un ou deux pour cent
d'un vivier initial de fusils marins qui
va finir par être nageur de combat
mais avant de tenter d'intégrer ce
commando mythique chaque soldat devra
d'abord obtenir son diplôme de plongeur
de bord
et c'est ici à l'école de plongée de
Saint-Mandrier-sur-Mer que tout se passe
depuis 70 ans les hommes et femmes de la
Marine nationale est plus récemment de
l'armée de terre de l'Armée de l'Air et
de l'Espace de la gendarmerie nationale
du service de santé des armées et les
sapeurs-pompiers de Paris y apprennent à
devenir plongeur de bord
vous connaissez l'espace entre chaque
repère le cours plongeur de bord est un
prérequis pour les différentes
spécialités que peut offrir la plongée
militaire un plongeur de bord peut
rester toute sa vie plongeur de bord ou
décider d'engager un cursus un peu plus
long donc ce soit le cours plongeur des
mineurs le cours nageur de combat le
cours plongeur hélicoptère et les
plongeurs hyperbaristes du service de
santé des armées
le quartier maître Yoann et le quartier
maître Sébastien sont deux jeunes marins
qui rêvent des profondeurs
j'ai voulu faire pour genre de bord
parce que j'ai j'en ai fait dans le
civil et j'ai un cousin qui était dans
l'armée avant et du coup il m'a fait
découvrir ça s'il m'a donné encore plus
envie on ce qui veut dire que je peux
faire la réparation de coq de l'hélice
il y a des problèmes s'il y a des filets
de pêche et vu que je vais partir
bientôt en campagne bah c'est quelque
chose que j'aimerais bien faire là-bas
pour que ça se trouve à Nouméa
14 si Yoann aimerait rester plongeur de
bord Sébastien lui regarde déjà plus
loin
puis c'est marin pompier sur le bâtiment
du pH à Chatonnay
et sur une mission que j'ai faite j'ai
vu les plongeurs des mineurs et c'est ce
qui m'a donné envie de faire plongeur
puis ensuite proposer à faire le point
des mineurs
vont devoir valider leur formation six
semaines d'instruction intense ou
s'enchaînent activité physique plongée
et court théorique
on commence et là tu notes on commence
par les pieds donc là les pannes les
chaussons le couteau on remonte la
ceinture est-ce que la ceinture est bien
réglée la ceinture est passée la
ceinture je dois pas pouvoir passer la
main en gros on plonge tous de la même
façon pourquoi parce que il faut que de
nuit ou dans des conditions de visite
qui soit limitées il faut qu'on puisse
intervenir sur la personne si elle est
inconsciente pour trouver son matériel
c'est une nuit quand je perds mon
couteau et que j'ai mon collègue à côté
de moi je sais qu'il va y avoir sur la
même jambe la même façon je sais que les
détendeurs le principal est sur un côté
et pas sur l'autre donc on peut agir
sans voir puisqu'on est gris de la même
façon
[Musique]
ouais c'est bon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour le mettre sur le dos
après quelques exercices de manipulation
du matériel en surface c'est l'heure de
plonger pour nos deux élèves
à nouveau Yoann et Sébastien apprennent
à déséquiper et rééquiper leur bloc de
plongée des manipulations qui permettent
de gagner en aisance aquatique mais
aussi d'apprendre à se désengager si on
se retrouve coincé sous l'eau
[Musique]
une plongée qui se termine par un
exercice particulier une remontée sur
expiration
à Saint-Mandrier les élèves sont
toujours en binôme lors de leur plongée
et accompagné par un instructeur un gage
de qualité pour leur formation mais
aussi et surtout une assurance de
sécurité en milieu caustique déjà il
faut que l'instructeur il soit capable
de gérer un accidenté et gérer l'élève
qui va être là en témoin et même
peut-être les deux peuvent se cartonner
nous on est habilité à le faire on est
entraîné pour le faire donc clairement
un instructeur pour deux c'est vraiment
le minimum qu'on peut donner ensuite il
y a beaucoup de gestes techniques c'est
un environnement qui est pas une autre
pour le coup il faut vraiment de
l'accompagnement et c'est pas du luxe
c'est le minimum avant du bloc sous
l'eau la sécurité est un enjeu essentiel
mais le risque zéro n'existe pas
d'hier là alors pour parer à toute
éventualité l'école de Saint-Mandrier
dispose sur place d'une antenne médicale
et d'un équipement adapté
donc là c'est le
cm20 qui est le caisson de recompression
le plus gros que son recompression qu'on
est ici à l'école de plongée qui est
capable de dans lequel on est capable de
prendre en charge deux accidents de
plongée simultanément et avec deux sas
qui nous permettent de faire des relèves
de personnels accompagnateurs ou de
médecins un outil qui permet de pallier
le principal risque de la plongée
l'accident de désaturation le mélange de
gaz respirait sous l'eau se comprime
sous l'effet de la pression subaquatique
et lors d'une remontée trop rapide ce
phénomène s'inverse et présente des
risques
elle risque sur l'organisme c'est qu'on
est des petites bulles comme ça dans
l'organisme qui qui voyagent dans
l'organisme alors tant que elles sont
d'une taille et d'un nombre modéré on
arrive à l'évacuer par la fonction
respiratoire et quand malheureusement
soit le nombre soit la taille des bulles
et trop ou trop importante ça peut
devenir pathologie et puis du coup on a
un petit retentissement on a un peu
avoir retentissement
cutanéo articulaires
pulmonaire et puis surtout neurologique
avec ce caisson on recrée
artificiellement la pression sous-marine
afin de respecter les temps et les
paliers nécessaires à tout remonter lors
d'une plongée profonde un équipement
dont il dispose à terre mais également à
bord des deux embarcations prévues pour
les exercices en pleine mer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors on reprend une respiration dites
normal
vous pouvez vous remettre dans votre
bulle imaginez que vous êtes dans l'eau
vous êtes en vacances où vous voulez ce
matin c'est une séance de sport un peu
particulière à laquelle nous apprentis
plongeurs prennent pas une séance de top
ou technique d'optimisation du potentiel
un mélange de sophrologie et de yoga
centré sur la respiration
en train de remonter à la palme pour
représenter un petit peu les mouvements
de palmes vous pouvez vous déplacer
tourner en rond des techniques adoptées
il y a quatre ans par la Marine
nationale et auquel les élèves ne sont
pas toujours habitués les élèves ne
soupçonnent pas l'importance de ces
exercices parce que il y en a qui arrive
bien les apnées et que selon pose pas de
problème seulement en fait le fait de
faire ces exercices de ce que ça va nous
permettre de nous détendre qui soit
aller sous l'eau de vraiment mécaniser
tous les gestes savoir quand ils
prennent la respiration le débit sur
lequel soufflait avec ses instruments et
du coup tout est ancré et les réflexes
deviennent naturels Sébastien en est
convaincu ces exercices vont l'aider à
progresser
[Musique]
vachement de la pression qu'on a un peu
la prise en consommer justement on voit
sur le cours donc du coup ça fait du
bien de temps en temps de le faire et ça
ça nous améliore tout ce qui est en
apnée
pour être calme et des grandes vacances
[Applaudissements]
programme de la plongée aujourd'hui
toute une série d'exercices pour mettre
en pratique et perfectionner ce qu'ils
ont appris depuis le début du stage
recherche de détendeur en apnée nage
sans palme et premier travaux manuel
autant de manipulations qu'ils vont
devoir maîtriser à la perfection des
exercices plutôt simples pour ce début
de stage mais la difficulté va augmenter
tout au long des 6 semaines
pour Yoann et Sébastien le travail
commence à porter ses fruits et les
progrès sont déjà perceptibles des
sensations confirmées par leurs
instructeurs
on arrive on voit qu'on est un peu plus
à l'aise dans l'eau au fur et à mesure
et voilà
on voit déjà de plonger la progression
qui a eu un trieur aujourd'hui
on a on a fait de nouveaux exercices et
déjà les uns aquatiques c'est bénéfique
quoi en deux jours déjà c'est pas mal
80% de réussite en moyenne Yoann et
Sébastien sont encore dans la course
pour valider leur cours s'ils y
parviennent ils feront partie des
quelques 13000 plongeurs de bord formés
depuis la création de l'école de
Saint-Mandrier
à l'auda l'ardoise au Premier Régiment
étranger de génie l'heure est au
préparatif car on est à la veille d'un
exercice de grande ampleur
particularité les plongeurs de combat du
sixième régiment du génie ont été
invités par leur camarades légionnaires
une
occasion unique pour eux de s'entraîner
hors de leur zone de confort
ça nous permet un peu de casser les
habitudes parce que forcément on
s'entraîne beaucoup sur Angers c'est un
très grand site qui est très adapté à la
plongée mais nous on y est toute l'année
on connaît tous les sites tous les
endroits tout le monde au spot tous les
moindres sortie d'eau et là ça va être
l'inconnu total donc on va se retrouver
en fait à vraiment travailler comme si
on était déployés aux endroits en fait
comme on devrait déployer sur les choses
qu'on ne connaît pas
on va partir semi équipé une partie en
néoprène une partie en sec et en fait
donc là je suis en train de préparer le
matériel qui me servira dans le kayak
quand je devrais passer de la partie
sèche à la partie humide donc tout est
bien organisé bien défini comme ça on
n'a pas de perte de temps et on peut le
faire même les yeux fermés donc on a
tous la même procédure le même la même
façon de ranger notre matériel qui fait
que tout est optimisé pour justement
gagner du temps à éviter de perdre du
délai sur le sur la mission comme ça en
fait on gagne du temps on arrive vu que
le premier point est rapide
[Musique]
une heure franchissement pour un bon 72
heures facile en autonomie vivre au
matériel pour pouvoir pallier à tous les
types de mission donc on a des choix à
faire des contraintes des réflexions qui
sont au sein de tous les équipiers et
là-dessus il y a pas vraiment de
hiérarchie en sorte tous le même matos
donc on est vraiment là pour travailler
ensemble
après une nuit d'infiltration le long du
Rhône nos plongeurs de combat arrive au
petit matin à proximité de leur premier
objectif ce pont qu'ils doivent
reconnaître
là ici on va regarder justement
l'état de pont c'est l'été de tuer ou
pas de pluie partiellement de pluie ou
sur un état de franchir puis après on
peut rester ici que deux ponts pour
savoir quel type de véhicules on pourra
faire franchir véritable faire de lance
lors de phase offensive les plongeurs de
combat sont un rouage primordial dans la
préparation de l'avancée du gros des
troupes restés en retrait
grâce aux informations collectées et
transmises ils assurent la continuité
des opérations
donc là on est en train de remonter les
comptes rendus de reconnaissance qu'on
avait reçu pour qu'ils puissent à partir
de maintenant savoir l'état de tout ce
que l'on a effectué depuis hier soir
du côté du centre opérationnel on suit
de près l'avancée des plongeurs de
combat
[Musique]
sur le Bangui pour le commandant romain
en charge des opérations le large
spectre de compétences de ses soldats
permet de transformer un obstacle en
avantage tactique
souvent l'aliment aquatique est vu là
dans les états majors et même après au
sein des éléments qui sont sur le
terrain plus souvent comme un obstacle
qu'on peut pas franchir ou qu'on va voir
des difficultés à franchir avec beaucoup
de coordination et je dirais au
contraire les plongeurs de combat du
génie vont être ceux qui vont pouvoir
évoluer et faire en fait de cette
obstacle un avantage pour s'infiltrer à
travers les lignes et demi entre
Chusclan et stups
la mission des plongeurs de combat ne se
limite pas qu'à l'infiltration et à la
reconnaissance
22h notre action ici ce soir conditionne
le déploiement de la brigade
si on n'est pas dans les temps pour
détruire ce succès la brigade pourra
éventuellement retarder sa manœuvre donc
ça c'est pas concevable
pour s'entraîner aujourd'hui pour être
prêt demain tel est l'objectif de ces
plongeurs de combat
dans un contexte géopolitique tendu et
conflictuel la préparation au combat de
haute intensité est une nécessité
à la tombée du jour le commando de
sapeur est en position et prêt à passer
à l'action
il y a une petite demi-heure donc tout
s'est bien passé on n'a pas été décelé
par les pays on a été en mesure du coup
de prendre tout le renseignement qu'on
avait besoin et donc là les garçons
partis exactement avec les charges
accompagné par un appui donc qui lui va
rester en permanence et ensuite une fois
qu'ils sont remis à feu tout le monde va
repasser ici récupérer les sacs et on
s'exprime
attention au nombre de charges qu'on
doit mettre on a fait des calculs pour
calculer précisément combien il fallait
pour détruire la structure et il faut
respecter le délégué des données pour la
mission donc nous a demandé de détruire
l'antenne pour pour 21h30
[Musique]
on peut charge donc la mission soit
accomplie dans les délais
[Musique]
capable d'être déployé au sol par voie
nautique mais aussi depuis les airs les
plongeurs de combat du génie donnent à
l'armée de terre à un avantage majeur
de son côté l'armée de l'air et de
l'espace n'est pas en reste sauf qu'ici
être plongeur ne veut pas dire que l'on
passe son temps sous l'eau il y aurait
cinq pas que ça
marche
Nicolas et Pierre sont sauveteur
plongeur sur la base aérienne de
Solenzara en Corse ils viennent d'être
appelés sur une mission d'entraînement
là aujourd'hui c'est un avion donc qui a
perdu contact radio radar depuis 40
minutes donc on envisage forcément le
pire c'est à dire le crash et il y a on
sait qu'il y a cinq personnes à bord on
sait pas si on a des adultes et des
enfants donc on va envisager d'avoir des
enfants aussi on va prendre tout ce
qu'il faut pour les secours
capable d'être prêt à décoller en 15
minutes pierre et Nicolas vont embarquer
à bord d'un hélicoptère Puma
ils sont accompagnés par un médecin une
infirmière et le reste de l'équipage
aussitôt dans les airs ils prennent la
direction des montagnes corses
à peine arrivé sur la zone de recherche
leur passage déclenche la balise de
détresse de l'avion crashé
bleu après confirmation les sauveteurs
entre en scène et pour assurer leur
sécurité ils peuvent compter sur le
treuliste dont le rôle est primordial
le but c'est qu'ils arrivent eux en bas
totalement intègre et donc vous avez vu
des certains cas là on est proche des
arbres proche il y a du souffle etc donc
on travaille beaucoup par sieste et
en fonction de la zone pile au désir on
essaye d'autres de trouver zone la plus
appropriée pour pour qu'ils arrivent
encore de sécurité et pour qu'on puisse
eux ils puissent faire leur opération de
sauvetage dans les meilleures conditions
il se décroche
procédure remonter arriver sur les lieux
de l'accident Nicolas et le docteur
draissent un premier bilan de l'état de
santé des victimes qu'il communique à
l'équipage
hémorragique à la mâchoire gauche avec
une grosse perte de sang au niveau du
sol suspicion de choc hémorragique
une fois qu'on a eu médicalisé tout le
monde et comme inconscient de des
risques qui vont inhérents à la zone on
va rapprocher la zone de treillage pour
pas de déplacer les visites trop loin et
gagner un maximum de temps pour les
monter dans la machine
[Musique]
une à une les victimes sont remontées à
bord puis c'est au tour des équipes
médicales et des sauveteurs de regagner
l'hélicoptère tout au long de
l'opération chaque geste est millimétré
le fruit d'un entraînement intensif pour
les équipes de la base de Solenzara
sur chaque responsables pour toujours
travailler en sécurité et puis pour que
nos victimes soient dans les meilleures
conditions possibles
pour devenir sauveteur plongeur c'est
encore à une sélection rigoureuse qu'il
faut se plier
six semaines de formation intense à
valider au sein de l'école des
sauveteurs plongeurs de l'Armée de l'Air
et de l'Espace à la fin de ce stage pour
ceux qui réussissent ils sont intégrés à
un des deux escadrons de métropole où il
y a des sauveteurs plongeurs donc la
ba120 à Cazaux ou là-bas à 126 à
solenzar et il commence une période de
six semaines de parrainage donc avec un
chef plongeur qui va les encadrer
pendant ces 6 semaines et reprendre
l'intégralité de la formation pour
l'appliquer à une phase opérationnelle
chaque année quatre à six jeunes
sauveteurs plongeurs sont formés ici à
Solenzara ils y apprennent comment
sauver des vies sur terre mais aussi en
mer
aujourd'hui on va simuler un sauvetage
de personnes qui sont sur un radeau de
survie
c'est un vol un peu particulier
puisqu'on a des jeunes à l'instruction
qui sont en train de terminer leur
sixième semaine de formation c'est une
grosse journée importante avec beaucoup
de pression
afin d'arriver au plus vite auprès des
victimes les deux apprentis sauveteurs
optent pour la technique dite du droping
un saut à quelques mètres de hauteur
depuis l'hélicoptère une manœuvre
courante grâce à laquelle les sauveteurs
plongeurs ont hérité du surnom de plouf
ils font leur premier bilan pour
établi va être évacué en priorité
notamment les plus blessés ce qu'ils ont
fait ils ont fait l'évacuation par
civière et ensuite ils reviennent sur le
canot pour évacuer les non blessés par
brassière
l'exercice se déroule sans encombre pour
les deux élèves sauveteurs une
satisfaction particulière pour Pierre
qui assiste à la scène
et forcément les voyants il y a de la
fierté d'avoir réussi et aussi un peu de
compassion de voir comment est-ce qu'il
réagit c'est de voir que ça va être nos
futurs collègues ça fait plaisir
qu'il soit sauveteur plongeur plongeur
des mineurs nageurs de combat plongeur
de combat du génie ou plongeur de bord
tous ces soldats contribuent avec
passion et détermination à écrire la
formidable épopée de la plongée
militaire et à remplir les missions
particulières dont ont besoin les armées
les garçons sont comme été ceux des
années 40
sont les mêmes ce sont des passionnés
qui vivent leur vie à 100 à l'heure dans
toutes les composantes de la plongée
exigeantes autant qu'exaltantes la
carrière de plongeur militaire ouvre le
champ des possibles à celui qui s'en
donne les moyens il met souvent posé la
question de quels conseils pourrais-je
donner un jeune qui voudrait embrasser
la carrière la seule chose que je dirais
c'est soyez passionné ayez des envies ne
doutez jamais de vous parce que comme le
disait le commandant il faut au
co-créateur des nageurs de combat pour
vouloir quelque chose il faut
oser pour oser il faut s'en donner les
moyens et ses moyens la plupart du temps
sommeil au fond de chacun d'entre nous
[Musique]